[Music]
let's go out to
alex in dallas texas what's up alex
hey dr john how are you doing today i'm
good my brother how are you oh i'm
beyond blessed i am beyond blessed how's
the uh fine fine state of uh texas there
i hear it's like the surface of the sun
these days
it's hot it's dry and i lose cell phone
signal about every hour so we're still
working on those 5g towers y'all should
y'all should secede you also just call
it
get rid of the federal government do it
do it on your own
oh man
no comment on that
remember the alamo all right so what's
up man
so i wrote all this down so that way i
can stay on my script and not ramble so
i'll give you a short background and
then my main question so cool
my ex-wife and i divorced back in
december after being together for ten
years five of those years being married
we have no children
here's my main question
how can i best continue to move forward
with my life owning and being proud of
my marriage and my divorce which i do
not regret one second of
but also not let it define who i am as a
person in my professional social and
spiritual life
number one
um
you're still grieving the loss of this
marriage huh
uh yes i am yeah
how or why did it end
um
there were
she had you know her uh faults i had my
faults i'm not going to lie and say that
i was the perfect husband by any means
um
she fell out of love with me
she i caught her seeing another guy okay
the issues that i have to realize for
myself was i put her as the center of my
world
my happiness relied on her she wasn't
happy i wasn't happy and i know i put i
know i put a lot of stress on her
because of that okay and
um you know it's very similar to your
book um i have to own that
and um i have to move forward with that
understanding that
i could have been better okay
um you could have been better and
um
she could have made different choices
too
yes yeah okay
um so the technical word is love
addiction
where we put another person at the
center of our world right as this anchor
that they're gonna complete us right the
old tom cruise thing i wrote about that
a little bit in that book
um
and the the
the super technical is codependent right
you've heard that phrase i'm sure
um
here's a couple of
things just to think through
one is
most of us have a picture of our in our
heads
even though it's common
of a divorced person
and then
we look in the mirror
and those two pictures don't align
right
it's hard to see yourself as somebody
who's been divorced
and in our culture we turn everything
into an identity so the words are you're
a divorcee right or is that the right
way to say it
uh you're divorced as as though that's
that's your new label that's your
identity um
instead of somebody who was married to
somebody wasn't perfect and that person
cheated on me
violated our marriage covenant
and um
now i'm
i had gone all in on somebody
and for a love addict for someone who's
codependent you went all in all in all
in you not only put all the cards the
dealer gave you you had some other cards
underneath in your back pocket that you
played too right you played every card
every every i had to steal cards if
that's what it does that's right you put
every card on the table and including
other people's cards that's a great way
to put it
and you still lost the hand
and there's a deflating
right where it's just
ugh
uh and i think you at some point you
i had this thought the other day um
somebody was on an airplane
and
they had a little kid a really small kid
like a three two or three year old the
cutest little girl and she was being
silly and goofy and also a little bit
grumpy the flight was long
and this person started swearing
started cursing
to the level that
i i was i was
i haven't felt like this in probably a
decade to where i've got just mechanisms
that are i'm gonna end up in a fist
fight
and i could feel my body heading in a
direction that i was like oh man this is
old john i don't know this guy
and i had a thought in that airplane
um that the newspaper would read you
know
40 year old male
and i thought i don't see myself as that
as that black and white label but that's
what i you know that's the that's the
truth that's really got to own it like
you said
and then the next statement is so then
what so then what am i going to do so i
chose obviously not to get a fist fight
on an airplane but you've got to just
say okay this is the way this is and
then my question's going to be what am i
going to do next right
um can i ask you a hard question
yeah of course you haven't let her go
yet have you
i think i'm still holding on to what we
used to have yes
but
i understand
and my heart doesn't want what we had
if that makes sense like i'm i'm holding
on to what we had early
but we
we just drifted over the last several
years our goals changed things we wanted
changed
uh we still cared about each other i
still i still care about her but
not anywhere what i used to have you
ever have you ever met with a someone
who's really struggles with heroin or
cocaine
or even meth
do you have any friends okay
um
one of the terms they use is chasing the
ghost
the the
the first time you use um folks who
become long-term addicts almost
universally i've heard say
oh i knew
i knew that first time whoa this is
going to be a part of my life
and you try to get high again and again
and again chasing that first or second
experience and you can never catch it
that's why they call it chasing ghosts
right
and you're all and you end up doing
things that you know are killing you
in service of chasing that thing
and if you are a true love addict
you can tell me intellectually i know
that wasn't good for me
i've never met somebody who struggles
with meth who's like no this is helping
me out i've never heard that
um
i've never heard met somebody i've spent
time with someone who's doing heroin who
says no this is actually pretty good for
me
so you can intellectually know this
isn't good for me i don't want this i'm
moving on
but your body can still be very much
addicted
to that person who looked at you at the
wedding ceremony and said i'm all in on
you too
there's something really intoxicating
about that right
yeah
and so at some point you're gonna have
to i wish i had different language here
you have to detox from that person
how often do y'all communicate
um
once every month and it's a text message
or two about
some stuff we're still working on
settling dividing
um
but really it's
not that often in fact we we don't even
live in the same part of the country she
lives completely across the country okay
um so physically seeing her obviously is
not even a thought
um
it kind of is a thought isn't it
it
it hasn't been in a while and i can and
i feel like i'm being honest when i say
that because
it
there was a lot you know the last time i
saw her would have been in
january
and it was
it was very hard yeah um but actually it
felt like it was a good way to close the
door cool okay um
so it was it was the closure that i
needed to move on obviously that doesn't
make the situation any easier right uh
when you're with somebody for a decade
but
now
she hey brother she was the air you
breathe
she was the thought she was
she was in the terms and the terms that
i put it in was she wasn't the son to my
universe but she was one of my planets
ah
okay
if that makes sense there there was
there was a lot of important things in
my life and you know she was
one of the top important things in my
life and maybe at times she did become
the son and that's where i have to look
at myself and say i i definitely uh
could have done that better so give me
one or two things that um you'll do
differently next time
put my needs first
what does that mean
um
speak up if there's
speak up if i'm not okay instead of
consistently trying to give parts of
myself
to a point where i'm not in an okay
place and then i can't be
everything that i am in a relationship
or friendship for that matter because
i'm too worried about how's the other
person feeling is the other person happy
um
am i giving my all so that way that
you know they they will love me
which i i know that that's completely
not true i want to challenge you okay
the things you just laid out are all
about performance
someone who loves you is gonna need you
to do some things when it comes to
meeting their needs right
but love is
starts with you looking in the mirror
and saying i'm worth being loved man
and you don't believe that
we're going to need a whole other call
for that
i know i know but listen anytime
somebody answers the way you just did
my heart breaks for you
because somebody should have told you a
long long time ago
that you've got value
that the because the the question
underneath the question i just asked you
is what does that mean and you said well
then i'm going to let my needs be heard
when i'm not okay
and i would say well you've got to
define what not okay means which means
you've got to define what okay means
which means you've got to define
what do i want with this one crazy
little life i got
and what am i worth what is my time
worth
and here's what i'll tell you about just
a fast four dollar because i know that's
probably a whole other call
you're worth being loved recklessly
you're worth somebody rolling over in
the middle of the night and waking you
up just to kiss you on the on the mouth
because why not
and you deserve to fall in bed asleep
without meds and you deserve to get up
in the morning
and have a cup of coffee because you
want to not because you have to
and you are worth a job that doesn't
take your soul from you but it also is
an addiction either because you're
probably a workaholic too if i we want
to go to another phone call is that fair
yeah yeah i actually i
i have a pretty decent work-life balance
i will say that but i am a busy person i
have to stay busy there you go
all it says this
um
when you can look in the mirror and say
i love that guy or let me say this way
you probably talk to yourself in a way
that you would never let somebody talk
to a stranger in your presence
i
so i've been doing john i've been doing
therapy for about two years now okay are
you working on self-talk
oh yeah okay i
i consistently
i want to go back to the person that i
was when i was 10. and i just want to
hold him and i just want to hug him have
you done that because
i have to do it a lot okay
and i just
what happened to ten-year-old alex
uh
ten-year-old alex
was
very very publicly embarrassed because
of his weight okay
by two strangers
and it started a
whole whole
um 15 20 years worth of
very very bad body dysmorphia eating
disorders
over training under eating
overeating um
because i looked in the mirror every day
and said i hate the person that i was
there you go
man
and i'm not and i'm very proud to say
that i i love myself and that's and
that's you know one of the reasons why
why i made this call is because
i do want to own
right everything that i had i want to
own that i went through that i want but
i don't want it to define me right
right
so listen let it go
set it down
you can't control your way through what
happens next
and yeah that's hard
it's real because here's why your
solution to
those mean people who embarrassed you
publicly
was this will never happen again
right
and this will never happen again comes
from some really firm resolve and that
resolve is really good
and our culture celebrates that resolve
it's good for you
to make some major behavioral changes
and to make some health changes all it's
good and then it becomes pathological
because the same behaviors that kept us
alive when we were kids kill us when
we're adults right
and so
uh and it melts our relationships so
the next path through is letting it go
have you written that 10 year old alex a
letter
yeah okay yeah i have was that good a
good experience
good
good as good as the wrong word it led
into a lot more than just a letter it
led into a
a book per se good good i got it saved
on a word file it's about 150 pages good
for you good for you
so now so here's the thing i read that a
lot now let's let's um so you you went
you've been through seasons of some
pretty intense exercise
okay
so let's um
let's take the next few steps and this
is for everybody listen
let's take the next few steps as though
it's an exercise plan okay
and what we're gonna what i mean by that
is
you can't go just run a marathon
tomorrow
and so you're gonna have to you have to
start practicing
and you've seen the couch to 5k and the
couch to marathon the couch to 10k
we're gonna do couch to well okay you've
got two years of therapy you know you've
been able to identify the epicenter
and i would even tell you that in many
ways you've talked about it enough
so here's a couple of things i'm gonna
give you as the path out okay
number one
um
you probably have a daily gratitude
practice of some sort but i want you to
get in the habit of that okay okay the
second thing is is i want you to
implement a weekly service into your
life and not even mowing somebody money
but find a place where you can volunteer
an hour here's what we're doing we're
getting outside of our head and we're
taking that camera that has been
scanning the inside of you for a long
time and we're going to point it outward
we're going to stop looking at the rear
view mirror we'll start looking at the
at the at the windshield okay
okay this is a practice and so just
getting out and seeing other people and
helping people meet needs
is an invaluable practice okay
it's um there's some data that suggests
it's a path out of depression it's a
path out of some of these behaviors
um are you a part of any sort of men's
group
um
i actually just moved to dallas about
three months ago so i'm looking for one
in person but i am a part of a couple
like virtual based okay i want you to
get off the computer and get with people
in real life
okay okay
um
get with some human beings in your
immediate area and there's gonna be some
sort of um
lovaholics anonymous or essay group or
whatever like there's going to be some
some groups there that you can circle up
with and just have another group of men
in your life okay
i show up once a quarter to a group here
in nashville right so
to check in and and to help out but also
man i need to show up too
um
uh
the the the title of the book escapes me
here but it's by pia melody
p-i-a-m-e-l-o-d-y
and i think the title might be love
addiction i want you to pick that book
up
um
she's the
guru
just a really powerful powerful read but
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
start practicing
not performing
we're gonna practice
i need to whenever you hear the words i
need to or i should i want you to stop
and be curious about that what do i need
to do right now
what i have to do right now versus
i'm good
i'm good
right it's hard man it's hard
so what i just one one last quick
question what would you what would your
advice
be to me
if i'm meeting somebody whether that be
at work or a social based event and
they're asking me about myself and it's
uh you know oh hi my name is so-and-so
and i am
they ask are you married you got kids no
divorce or something you know whatever
the answer is and then that's that
automatic label
that's
all your brother that is that is your
baggage
if you meet somebody
and you feel the need to explain your
marital status
that's you
bringing that to that conversation
if they ask you are you married and you
go no not married divorced
and they choose
to create a story about you what that
word means about you you don't want to
spend time with that person
right exactly okay
so don't take that extra baggage with
you and this is going to be something
you practice
okay
you have made the word divorce a scarlet
letter
wait and and
so when when i went through my divorce
um
even i was a part of some in person i
did some virtual as well but a lot of
support groups
and i ended up leaving them in about two
weeks
because these people were just
they were so angry
i mean they were rightfully so yeah i
mean i i was i was disappointed i was
angry but like
i still don't regret it um
so so but yeah you left those groups
thinking that you something's wrong with
you
or you left those groups with some sort
of introspection that i'm not angry like
this i don't want to be around this but
am i not doing this right am i right
yeah exactly i felt like well what what
is wrong with me because they keep
telling me that you should be so mad you
should be so no no listen listen
that is
love addiction
you are outsourcing your feelings to
other people
in the hopes that they will do it better
than you can do it
and that's a person who innately does
not trust themselves
and underneath that is a person who
innately does not love themselves
see what i'm saying
who cares what a group of strangers on
the internets think about you
who cares they don't get a vote
they don't get a vote right
it's cool for them to help out and say
hey here's a common experience we're
having
but if your body says dude there's a
bunch of angry people and yeah i'm
heartbroken it was hard but it was right
right um well and that's the thing is is
like i'm still like i'm still here i'm
still proud of myself yes and everything
that i've done and like that's where i'm
like
i don't need this then don't yeah then
walk away you're there you just gotta
take that last step
hold your head up high
you're alex from freaking dallas texas
hold your head up high
lone star stage
hey hold your head up high okay you went
through something hard you had to make
some hard decisions you had to look in
the mirror you've done two years of hard
therapy
you have some early traumas that you've
been wrestling with you've done a ton of
heavy heavy lifting
and it's kind of like this
you know when you uh
um you probably experienced this right
when you were really focused on weight
loss and i'm gonna be thin you'd run
into people that hadn't seen you in a
while
and they were like whoa you look great
and you didn't see it like that because
you just seen it little bits and pieces
every day over the course of one year
two years ten years however long
that's you right now
so in a weightlifting metaphor you
have been lifting in a
dim lit rocky iv style gym for the last
couple of years
heavy lifting hard
and then you just came out in the light
and you don't realize how big you've
gotten how muscular you've gotten how
strong you've gotten how good you look
and you're gonna go back to the same
people who have the same labels as you
and they haven't put the work in you've
put in or they're at the very beginning
of their journey they're just heading
into that gym
that's great that's good this is not
where you are right now and so those are
people we're going to love we're going
to walk alongside them if they invite us
as mentors and friends
but we're not going to
we're not going to work out with them
they can't lift our weight they can't
even spot us
we're gonna surround ourselves with real
people in the world that are gonna do
life with us and dude you have to decide
to put that label down it is it just is
so i'm gonna hold my head up high when i
meet people yeah
i'm divorced if you want to dig into it
more
my wife cheated on me
and i'm a person of character and
standards and i believe that um
my uh covenant stands for something
and my wife violated a covenant i love
her
lover good friend good human uh but
violated our covenant and so i'm not
gonna remain there
they want to get into it right
but they're not going to that's you
bringing your baggage to that label set
it down man
i'm really really proud of the work
you've done alex you've come a long long
way now it's time to enact it now it's
time to start taking those little baby
steps towards the new marathon a whole
new way of being alive
and i start to look in the mirror and
say it i'm alex and
i've got
value i'm worth being loved starting
with you my brother i'm proud of you